and now San Francisco has something
called the Civic Joy fund the fund
kick-started by a gift has received
contributions from Levi Silicon Valley
investor Joby pritzker and Eventbrite
power couple Julia and Kevin Hans the
artists and musicians the go-go dancers
the drag performers the pole dancers
they are what make San Francisco special
so they're countering the drug epidemic
with pole dancers that's going to be the
first line of defense to a city that is
like completely fallen and is unsafe and
they're going but if we had pole dancers
in the streets and more dread performers
it would be better maybe maybe that's
what you need to do just make it a
little fun make it if people are going
to die
and people are going to get maimed and
robbed at least you can make it uh
exciting and fun and quirky and campy